bonjour et bienvenue dans cette dernière
édition de la saison pour europe hebdo
dans cette émission direction la grèce
nous avons été enquêté sur le patrimoine
de l'église orthodoxe
un patrimoine qui vous le verrez suscite
de plus en plus la polémique
nous parlerons ensuite euro de football
avec la victoire éclatante de l'espagne
mais d'abord at on vraiment sauver
l'union
c'est la question de la semaine c'était
l'éternel sommet de la dernière chance
le 19e exactement deux ans et demi de
rebondissements de volte face de
conciliabules un soap opéra à
l'européenne en sommes à la clé des
mesurettes des reports et souvent plus
souvent de l'indécision et l'art
finalement un soir de juin
enfin un accord pacte de croissance
fonds permanent project bouge on y voit
les prémices d'une union bancaire et
budgétaire
on dit même quand gainey aurait capitulé
face aux pays du sud ces nations du club
med englués dans leurs dettes et même
les grands méchants marchés semblent
rassurés mais pour combien de temps
parce que la grèce l'italie l'espagne le
portugal chypre la france des pays
entiers étouffe sous le poids de leur
dette et sur les pavés des rues
européennes restent les peuples les
peuples condamnée à la rigueur
alors at-on vraiment sauver l'union at
on vraiment sauver d'union c'est un
petit peu la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui et pour y répondre c'est
daniel cohn-bendit qu'on reçoit merci
d'être avec nous alors est ce que il
faut se réjouir des conclusions de ce
sommet où est ce que c'est encore un sur
six balles et deux c'est déjà pas mal
qui est un sursis donc on peut se
réjouir pour le sursis mais c'est vrai
que c'est un petit pas en avant et
maintenant il faut voir si on va
confirmer même si on ose penser qu'on va
transformer l'essai il y à un pas vers
une solidarité face à la dette donc une
communautarisation une mise en commun de
la dette ou des d'instruments pour
soulager certains pays des taux
d'intérêt il y a une idée maintenant
d'une union beaucaire donc d'une
supervision bancaire enfin on voit
disons que ça les fait miss quoi un
système européen sme est en place
maintenant on a vu deux jours après le
gouvernement l1 qui a et amsterdam dit
non non on a décidé ça papa papa on veut
pas on dit on n'a pas décidé ça alors
maintenant on discute sur quoi on a
décidé tout ça c'est pas mal hein disons
etc pour les marchés non plus c'est pas
mal hein mais disons qu'au sommet j'ai
l'impression qu'on a fait un pas en
avant même si c'est insuffisant et il
faut aller vers où là maintenant que
maintenant qu'on a on en est arrivé là
après je crois le l'est pas alors pour
la crise yade
il ya deux débats y ait un débat c'est
l'avenir de l'union de la structure
politique de l'union fédéralisme pas ça
ça met du le ça met du temps c'est pas
pour ça répond pas à la crise et la
crise et bien voilà c'est il faut qu'il
y ait un fonds d'amortissement de la
dette européens
il faut qu'il y ait un budget européen
conséquent pour pouvoir relancer
l'économie
et là le débat central sur le budget
européen c'est les ressources propres un
peu pas oui enfin c'est à dire si on met
une partie de la taxe sur les
transactions financières dans le budget
européen
si on n'élève taxe carbone au niveau
européen si on fait une taxe sur la
téléphonie mobile dans l'espace européen
2 0 bien mal pour cent sur tous les
coups de téléphone ou sur les liaisons
internet
enfin il y a des tas de possibilités de
ressources propres pour le budget où on
ne dépendrait pas d état et du problème
donc d'être utile contribution des états
membres et du problème de leur situation
financière
alors il ya aussi un autre problème là
qui sait qui s'est soulevée ces derniers
jours c'est le cas anglais qui fin au
royaume uni on se demande si on va pas
faire un référendum pour sortir de
l'euro good bye good bye essner dit en
l'air c'est pas un problème d affaiblir
encore l'union européenne non non non
parce que moi je crois qu'il ya une
hypocrisie fondamental c'est que
l'angleterre veut participer au marché
unique mais ne veut pas faire d'effort
et toute cette idéologie
nous voulons notre argent tout ça ils
ont droit depuis après l'angleterre sera
dehors il y aura des accords commerciaux
avec l'angleterre 1 l'angleterre doit
décider dans un référendum il est simple
le référendum anglais si ça dépendait de
moi vous allez me dire c'est les
contraintes moi c'est autre chose
c est ce que vous voulez rester le 27e
28e état européen où est ce que vous
voulez être le 51e état des états unis
choisissent et faites votre choix
mesdames et messieurs
l'avenir est à vous mesdames et
messieurs les anglais tirez les premiers
et puis voilà et puis décideront et puis
ils ont le droit de décider de vouloir
être simplement anglo-américain ça lui
ferait pas d'assez bien l'union
européenne et l'union européenne
ce que ceux qui veulent l'union
européenne
on peut pas obliger un peuple à être
dans l'union s'il ne veut pas c'est
comme ça c'est la vie évidemment qu'on
pourrait imaginer une europe plus forte
avec l'angleterre comme moi je peux
imaginer une europe plus forte avec la
turquie
un joli assez bon mais maintenant il
faut que les peuples il faut que ça
fonctionne ensemble si ça ne fonctionne
pas c'est le l'histoire du dernier
sommet c'est quand même la folie ils ont
parlé un peu de la crise mais ils ont
parlé du brevet européen
ils ont prouvé du siège européen alors
les anglais nous casse les pieds sur les
deux sièges européens
strasbourg et bruxelles qu'on peut
discuter mais alors là ils ont proposé
trois sièges pour le siège du brevet
européen pour collier de londres dedans
non mais c'est complètement marteau
cette histoire donc que les anglais se
décide
goodbye au welcome c'est à voir
alors françois hollande a également
décidé finalement de signer ce pacte
budgétaire est ce que c'est un reniement
selon vous il a elle décidé il a raison
c'est un compromis européen si on veut
la croissance si on veut une
communautarisation une solidarité dans
la dette
eh bien il faut accepter aussi qu'il y
ait un effort alors ça sera pas
l'inscription de la règle d'or dans de
la règle d'or dans la constitution
française mais il y aura une loi
organique pour aller vers un équilibre
budgétaire
quand on sait que la france paye 50
milliards doit dépenser chaque année 50
milliards pour la dette pour payer les
taux d'intérêt il faut arrêter et ils
ont raison quand ils disent
pendant les dépendants le
le quinquennat de sarkozy ou de prudence
a augmenté de 500 ou 600 milliards la
dette
on va par an commenté encore de 600
milliards est devenu le premier poste
après l'éducation nationale est
exactement donc on est obligé de
stabiliser le budget donc maintenant il
faut inventer alors là je crois qu'il ya
des débats après avoir sur la fiscalité
écologique études je veux pas lancer
maintenant mais que l'on signent le
pacte c'est juste si on a la composante
solidarité qu'il faut encore
perfectionner et si on a la confiance de
la de la relance qu'il faut que ça soit
une relance verte pour nous les
écologistes alors daniel cohn bendit il
ya une autre actualité qui a intéressé
nos confrères des télévisions
européennes c'est l'euro de foot avec
notamment la victoire de l'espagne qui
comme vous le verrez dans cette
sélection préparé par aurélie la face à
parfois largement dépassé l'analyse
footballistiques
l'euro est à la une mais qu'elle vaut
crise de la monnaie ou match de football
sur la bbc les deux sujets se mélangent
en fait je souhaite que la grèce game
mais je pense que c'est l'allemagne qui
va gagner comme ça ne seront amenés à
jouer contre eux le gagnant devrait
choisir quelles sont les conditions du
plan de relance italie allemagne une
autre opposition sur le terrain comme
dans les coulisses du sommet européen
et dans les deux cas l'italie fait de la
résistance non il ne fait pas l'accord
européen mais bien la victoire de
l'italie en demi-finale de l'euro
les journalistes regardent au football
discrètement les chefs d'état aussi les
négociations s'enlisent à la table des
il leur aura fallu 15 heures de
discussions pour pouvoir dire à l'aube
il ya eu des décisions alors trouver un
accord sur un plan de relance européen
devait être une formalité
mais l'espagne et l'italie les deux
finalistes de l'euro ont bloqué net
le football est devenu une fierté
nationale mais aussi une source d'espoir
pour les espagnols nous nous sentons
fier de ce qui est en train de se passer
et nous espérons vraiment réalisé ce que
personne n'a jamais réalisé
cela ferait du bien à tout le monde au
football espagnol mais aussi à notre
pays
je pense que ce sont des signes de
progrès espérons que tout ce qui se
passe dans le sport espagnol pourra se
produire à l'échelle de la société
vraiment espérons
alors daniel cohn bendit on a parlé de
revanche des pays du sud sur les pays du
nord est ce que on a été un peu loin en
ses lectures ou pas non il faut dire une
chose d'abord le football espagnol
ça fait extrêmement du bien au football
en général parce que c'est vraiment
voilà un jeu et pas nous est un jeu
formidable donc c'est ça c'est de l'art
c'est du grand art donc voilà respectons
et approuvons et disons bravo à ce grand
art alors après les jeux politiques
c'est normal c'est normal qu'on touche
l'allemagne
ça aurait été drôle que la grèce bat
l'allemagne c'est vrai il y aurait eu
comme ça une ironie de l'histoire ça n'a
pas eu lieu
mais bon l'italie a gagné tout le monde
voyait les allemands avaient déjà le
problème des allemands c'est que il
croyait avoir gagné c'est vrai que mal
un marqueur allant au sommet croyait
déjà avoir gagné puis voilà ça s'est pas
passé comme ça c'est la vie c'est la vie
ça se passe pas toujours comme on croit
on a été un petit peu loin dans cette
île faut pas prendre trop ça trop au
sérieux
c'est un jeu et on a le droit de jouer
faux pas et hop et de seigle dans la vie
donc on jours voilà ya l'euro il ya le
show met donc on essaye d'avoir des
idées alors il y en a qui sont bonnes y
qui sont pas bonnes mais le fait est que
voilà l'italie battant l'allemagne c'est
un clin d'oeil le soir où monty met en
échec la stratégie de la marque dans
gala merkel bon voilà c'est si ni plus
ni moins alors après il ya quand même un
autre problème c'est que mine de rien le
football espagnol est un des plus
endettés d'europe
est ce que on va pas un petit peu aussi
dans le dans le même sens à ce qu'on
n'est pas dans une bulle
un peu spéculation une bulle c'est
vraiment il ya une crise du football en
espagne c'est vrai c'est que c'est à
l'image de du toujours plus toujours
plus vite c'est vrai que disons
l'initiative de michel platini diola
financière efficience financier est tout
à fait juste c'est à dire que le rapport
entre les salaires est ce que les
rentrées des clubs il faut qu'il y ait
un équilibre donc ça ça va le problème
c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on a quelque chose de nouveau c'est où
les milliardaires russes abramovitch ou
le qatar c'est çà et là c'est pas
fair-play germain s'est pas fair-play
j'allais finir parce que mettre en place
donc c'est michel platini président de
l'uefa qui veut mettre ça en place c'est
en vigueur depuis le 1er juin 7 se fair
play financier c'est-à-dire exclure de
certaines compétitions pourquoi pas les
clubs qui sont en déficit excessif le
problème c'est que quand vous avez
abrahamowicz derrière vous où l'émir du
qatar ça veut dire que vous créez un
espèce de championnat européen à deux
vitesses
voilà qui vont pouvoir se refinancer et
d'autre part c'est un problème donc
c'est vrai qu'il a il faut trouver dans
la régulation financière donc le fair
play financier
il faut trouver aussi une limite à
l'apport financier venant de l'extérieur
c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'il y ait
qu'un club puisse démontrer que ses
dépenses en deux rapports avec ses
entrées dans le sport et non pas
extérieur on peut le faire ça et je
crois que c'est donc il faut affiner
l'idée du fait très les lanciers
d'accord mais à l'heure où il ya aussi
d'autres problèmes qui sont qui ont été
soulevées notamment en italie avec les
paris sportifs on a vu des conditions
corruption matches truqués et ses
caisses que fait l'europe pour ça ce qui
est une possibilité d'agir
bah je veux dire sur le fair play
financier etc deraa l'europe peut jouer
sur la régulation du foot qu'est ce que
souvent des entreprises européennes les
clubs de foot sur les paris en ligne
saas et la justice normale je veux dire
il ya une justice des justices
nationales
évidemment que ça se passe au niveau
national et on peut pas y a pas une
justice européenne sur ce histoire de
paris parce que c'est pas un manque de
régulation quand même non vous savez cc
on a toujours tout c'est là où il ya des
paris a toujours eu de la triche 1 il
faut faut pas le maintenant trop élevé
enfin font pas exagérer c'est
malheureusement la vie hein
donc c'est pas le roi l'europe selon le
problème c'est l'italie à la capacité
aujourd'hui de mettre entonné puis le
problème c'est ce qu'ils vont oser
s'attaquer à bouffonne qui a mis que le
goal de l'équipe d'italie camille je
sais pas combien de centaines
de milliers d'euros en pariant alors je
sais pas ce qu'il en était mais c'est
assez bizarre quand même
pour dire la moindre chose mais bien un
autre problème si vous voulez poser un
problème européen sur le sport ça lui il
ya il ya une enquête pendant la coupe du
monde en afrique du sud 71% des joueurs
prennent des médicaments pendant le
championnat la coupe du monde donc la
même chose maintenant pour l'euro 1 36 %
prennent pour tous les matchs des
anti-inflammatoires 51% de parts - c'est
entre les médicaments et le dopage
alors là dieu seul sait et le sport
espagnol effectivement et très le sport
espagnol mais c'est parce que tous ces
titres si tout le monde il faut pas tout
nous on est tout le monde fait jacques
anquetil maintenant j'attends d'ici là
vous et il se dopait il avait les fesses
fermes de piqûres c'est lui-même qui le
dit hein donc je veux dire voilà et on
est tous responsables
puis on est extasié devant ses joueurs
qui font l'euro ils ont fait plus de 60
matches dans l'année donc en contrôlant
ont maintenant loin et on demande le
foot spectacle la télévision qui demande
plus de matches vous rencontrez que on a
fait une chose complètement aberrante
pas ce qu'il fallait pour la télévision
fallait qu'ils aient un match par jour
eh bien eh bien ça veut dire qu entre
les quarts de finale et demi-finale il
deux jours de différence entre l'italie
et l'allemagne de repos c'est pas fair
play ça parce que on voulait pas mettre
deux matches un après-midi et 1 le soir
mais ça n'a pas empêché les italiennes
gallier là pour le coup est ce que vous
savez quand vous avez une défaillance
physique vous devez rattraper ça d'une
certaine manière alors c'est là où il ya
un problème il faut savoir comment donc
je veux dire moi le problème de la
régulation de match de l'effort physique
c'est la même chose pour le tour de
france
on veut un tour de france de plus en
plus compétitif de plus en plus dur
c'est à dire qu'on pousse au dopage
on pousse sait si c'est trop dur c'est
pas possible à 41 42 43 km de moyenne je
crois si vous faites du vélo
non pas encore
6 et moi j'en fais un peu mais à mon
niveau quand vous avez monté une fois le
ventoux vous dites mais c'est pas
possible qu'ils fassent à 20h07
et qu'est ce que justement fait l'europe
pour ça il ya une possibilité d'agir et
de réguliers sur ça moi je crois que sur
la régulation sur le dopage et le
contrôle l'europe aller beaucoup plus
loin et émettre des lois qui serait
beaucoup plus dure que celle qui existe
en ce moment bon bah écoute et en
attendant on suivra le dossier merci
beaucoup
daniel cohn-bendit d'avoir été parmi
nous est ce que vous connaissez le
patrimoine de l'église orthodoxe grecque
oui je sais qu'il est énorme et le
problème le patrimoine de l'église pour
être franc c'est qu'il ya eu un accord
après la guerre entre l'église orthodoxe
grecque et l'état grec
ils ont donné une partie de leur terrain
à l'état et en contrepartie ils ont eu
un accord qu'ils ne payent pas d'impôts
c'est çà et là aujourd'hui à l'heure de
la rigueur
la session faut remettre ça mais vous
savez le mois ce qui m'enrichit en grèce
je dis ça parce que j'ai souvent des
gens dire c'est que le premier ministre
le élus great porte serment sur la
voiture devant l'église en dehors j'ai
effectivement on croit rêver
on croit rêver ben justement il est au
moyen-âge
c'est justement ce dont nous allons
parler tout de suite avec monsieur
sloboda qui est votre collègues et
confrères du parlement mais pour le
groupe socialiste et démocrate et nous
en attendant on part à athènes avec
thomas raguet
athènes à deux pas du centre nous sommes
dans le principal point de distribution
alimentaire de la ville une distribution
organisée par l'église
il est 15 heures une foule compacte
d'immigrés et de grecs se pressent pour
recevoir un repas chaud s'il vous plaît
vous allez tous est servis les repas
sont distribués par des bénévoles de la
paroisse voisine phénomène a également
été les matraques ont distribué un repas
par jour il vient me 300 portions
les repas sont cuisinés ni embarquer par
un traiteur qui les livrent ensuite ici
tout est payé par 20 minutes vont
suffire pour écouler près de 1300 repas
la demande est en hausse constante sur
les 515 points de distribution de
l'archevêché on est passé de 5000 à
10000 et depuis six mois on est à 12
mille cinq cents repas distribués par
jour cette action sociale l'église
grecque la revendique
en pleine crise économique et lui permet
de faire face à des critiques de plus en
plus vives visant ses privilèges et son
exceptionnel patrimoine évalué à
plusieurs milliards d'euros selon
certaines sources officieuses
il reste très difficile à estimer
en grèce l'église n'est pas séparée de
l'état les religieux à l'exception des
moines sont des fonctionnaires 9000 au
total pour un budget annuel des cultes
de 350 millions d'euros dans un pays où
le premier ministre prête serment sur la
bible passe au clergé l'église est
intimement lié au pouvoir la
constitution grecque
il fait explicitement référence et rares
sont ceux qui osent la critiquer
l'église est bien entendu très forte
vous avez des députés qui ne sont plus
que grâce à l'assistant au concours de
l'église est en fait il y a que très peu
dans la vie politique
très peu de gens son patrimoine l'église
l'a héritée de l'occupation ottomane
les grecs pouvait alors lui léguer leurs
biens pour éviter qu'il tombe aux mains
des tur résultat elle possède de
nombreux lieux de culte 450 monastère et
surtout des milliers d'hectares de
terres à travers tout le pays
plus surprenant l'église nous des
bâtiments immeubles d'habitation villa
sur l'un de ses terrains l'école
ecclésiale d'athènes a même fait bâtir
ce complexe commercial et un parking
dont elle perçoit les rentes en clair
l'église et ses différentes entités
n'hésitent pas à investir pour faire
fructifier leurs biens une stratégie
qu'elle assume totalement il ya un
patrimoine très important mais il faut
trouver les moyens pour pouvoir utiliser
cette patrimoine pur produit quelque
chose on est salarié
on touche chaque mois notre salaire on
n'a pas besoin d'avoir un intérêt par
tous les actes qu'on veut faire et tous
les l'argent tous les produits vont
rester à l'église et on va utiliser pour
l'église et est ce que signifient les
peuples
bref l'église met en avant la croissance
engendrés par ces investissements et la
redistribution de l'argent ainsi gagné
ce qui est tout à fait scandaleux
c'est le traitement de l'église du point
de vue taxe dément de taxes etc
il y à un certain nombre de privilèges
tout à fait exorbitants et en fait aucun
contrôle
fiscales nettes exercé à l'égard de des
prélats et des évêchés la position de
l'église
un sujet qui fâche surtout quand
l'opinion a appris à l'automne dernier
qu'elles seraient exemptés d'une
nouvelle taxe foncière au ministère de
l'éducation nationale dont dépendent des
cultes on tient à préciser les choses
les choses sont claires
l'église en ce qui concerne ses
activités en dehors de l'adoration
elle-même bay la même chose que tout le
monde si elle loin biens immobiliers
elle paye une taxe comme vous et moi
pour couper court à la polémique le
saint synode a récemment publié sa
contribution fiscale 12 millions d'euros
en 2011 une somme en nette hausse par
rapport aux années précédentes car
depuis 2010
ses revenus sont taxés à hauteur de 20%
quant à l'impact budgétaire des cultes
le message est clair à la haine papier
point de vue strictement économique
capital gestion salaire n'est rien 16e
et 15 comparé à ceux dont la société
bénéficie de la part de l'église en
grèce parler de séparation de l'église
et de l'état est quasiment à bout et les
rares projets de réforme d'envergure ont
généralement été bien vite enterré dans
un pays où 90% de la population est
orthodoxe l'influente église grecque
dominera encore longtemps la vie
publique
et pour évoquer cette question de la
richesse de l'église nous recevant hans
voevoda merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
le président du groupe socialiste et
démocrate au sein de ce parlement
l'église orthodoxe grecque et la
deuxième enfin et là deuxième
propriétaire de foncier en grèce est ce
que ça vous choque un peu oui parce que
je suis pour la séparation entre l'état
et l'église
et je suis pour la justice et l'égalité
c'est pourquoi il faut trouver un
système de taxation en grèce qui est
juste et équitable pour toutes les
personnes et tous les institutions mais
bien sûr on peut introduire quelques
exceptions réduction des taxes pour
investissement dans la patrimoine c'est
clair c'est naturel
mais il faut trouver une taxation juste
pour tous les genres pour tous les
institutions en grèce l'église par
l'église c'est l'obligation maintenant
du gouvernement en crète alors on voit
aussi que la grèce là entre dans sa
cinquième année de récession
est ce qui est une possibilité un jour
pour qu'elle s'en sorte est ce qu'on
n'est pas juste en train d'étouffer le
pays est ce qu'on n'est pas en train de
me tuer à petit feu
il y a des possibilités des chances a
permanent absolument de demander une
forme avec de construction comme jeudi
d'une administration efficace pour les
actions mais pour les autres sujets
aussi parce que sans une administration
efficace
on ne peut pas inviter les investisseurs
en grèce et c'est pourquoi les demandes
primodial sont concentrés edouard
concentrer sur cette question d'un
introduction de l'établissement d'une
administration efficace en grèce c'est
pour l'état pour les régions pour
levy et cetera parce que seulement avec
une association efficace on peut comme
je dis invité les investissements
investissements sont nécessaires pour la
grèce c'est pas les choses pour réduire
la consommation
les salaires les retraites on fait ça
déjà c'est fini maintenant vous les gars
vous dit stop
c'est ça la politique de rigueur et on
doit commencer avec une politique de
croissance décroissance c'est l'argent
cette politique de croissance et annonce
beaucoup d'argent puis on dresse
l'église peut-être mais beaucoup
d'argent à la banque
les banques devant la suisse raisons
fiscales et futurs il ya des paradis
fiscal donc dans ce monde aussi en
europe
et là il faut fait dans ce cas là contre
ça parce que les paradis fiscaux c'est
pas juste la grèce qui dit voilà moi
j'ai eu tant de milliards qui se sont
envolés dans des paradis fiscaux
effectivement ça a été le cas il ya les
armateurs qui sont pas cet accès il ya
le patrimoine de l'église
donc on sent qu'il ya quand même de
l'argent comment aller chercher cet
argent là est ce qu'il ya des leviers
possibles
et est ce que l'union européenne aussi
aidé la grèce à faire ça on n'en a pas
vraiment l'impression c'est parce que
vous semblez faire pour l'instant
j'ai demandé il ya maintenant plus d'un
an la présidente de la suisse
vous êtes prête à négocier une un traité
avec la grèce concernant l'évasion
fiscale oui et non oui je suis prêt mais
aujourd'hui rien autriche a fait ça
l'allemagne a fait plus ou moins ça des
autres pays a fait ça mais la grèce non
et c'est pourquoi l'union européenne la
commission européenne il il faut presser
il faut avoir un dialogue très forte
avec la grèce avec le gouvernement
d'établir cette accession alors oui on
peut quand même au moins reconnaître un
avantage à la l'église c'est qu'elle
pallie aussi les carences de l'état
notamment sur l'aide aux plus démunis
l'alleud les plans de rigueur successifs
ont fini par étouffer la population
est ce qu'au fond c'est on n'est pas en
train de créer une génération perdue que
ce soit en grèce ou en espagne au
portugal
là on voit que ça va être bientôt
peut-être le cas encore à chypre qu'est
ce qu'on fait en fait de ces populations
on dit souvent que l'europe sauver les
banques mais pas les peuples
est ce que on est en train de créer une
europe des banques et pas une europe des
peuples c'est vrai c'est pourquoi pour
moi l'expression union de banques c'est
une expression fausse parce qu'il faut à
créer une union de supervision des
banques mais pas une union des banques
en europe
il faut commencer avec une soutien forte
de lutter contre le chômage spécialement
chômage des jeunes
il est possible montée de notamment
l'espagne veut il trompé en autriche il
est possible on a commencé les ouïes
commencée il ya 10 au 15 années déjà
c'est facile après dix années d activité
mais il faut commencer des activités
maintenant en grèce en espagne et setra
parce que c'est une génération perdue
vous avez tout à fait raison il faut on
ne peut pas convaincre les gens qui sont
au chômage
l'europe c'est beau l'europe se donnant
vata jeu le rapport aux aides et
maintenant on commence à discuter le
futur de l'europe les changements de
traité mais les gens sont là sans son
emploi on ne peut pas dire oui à une
épreuve à vos offres d'emploi mais
discute avec moi le futur de l'europe
c'est pas possible c'est pourquoi c'est
pourquoi c'est pas une question
économique et social cela c'est une
question politique
les gens vont voter pour l'extrême
d'extrême gauche mais plutôt un seul
doigt bon ben écoutez en attendant cette
question du futur de l'europe va nous
occuper encore un long moment
merci beaucoup monsieur et madame avoir
été reçus nous on se retrouve la saison
prochaine justement pour continuer à
discuter de cette question de futures et
et bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires
à